[Musique]
regarder alors ça inspire vraiment du
Z fold 4 de Samsung pour autant c'est la
propre version de Huawei avec un grand
écran intérieur grand écran extérieur
également et surtout extrêmement fin
plus fin a priori celui de Samsung donc
ça c'est plutôt pas mal donc ça je
trouve ça assez sympa j'aime bien le dos
j'aime bien également le module photo
que je trouve assez joli et assez
élégant alors pour autant est-ce qu'ils
ont réussi à le vendre j'en sais
strictement rien l'avenir nous le dira
en tout cas je trouve ça marrant de voir
toujours ouais dans l'innovation avec ce
smartphone c'est le mate X3 est-ce qu'il
marchera ou pas allez savoir en tout cas
il est là il est beau il est joli je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez dites le
moi dans les commentaires